comme un air de résultats au
baccalauréat les yvelinois se sont
massivement fait dépister avant les
fêtes de noël
des tests effectués avant tout pour se
rassurer pour retrouver ses proches le
soir même à tout simplement par sécurité
par rapport à mes enfants et mes petits
enfants ma compagne s'est fait tester
ces fêtes testé hier mes beaux parents
aussi c'est pas forcément très agréable
mais ça a été beaucoup venant surtout
par précaution le taux de négativité et
très élevé depuis deux jours j'ai que
des résultats négatifs
la semaine dernière les gens qui
venaient en fait ils avaient des
symptômes ils avaient des troubles dys
poser des questions donc j'avais 5 10%
de positif aujourd'hui c'est que des
gens qui veulent se prévenir pour ne pas
être contaminants pendant le dîner de
famille les files d'attentes dans les
pharmacies se sont remplies tout au long
de la matinée
les papiers sont effectués au comptoir
avant de réaliser le test antigénique
dans un local aménagé les résultats
donnés en 15 minutes
il y a dix fois plus de tests depuis le
début de la semaine que la semaine
dernière les gens ils sont super
contents parce que ils peuvent faire la
fête malgré les tests les gestes
barrière ne seront pas oubliés pendant
le repas du réveillon les précautions
seront prises quoi qu'il arrive après
c'est plus pour mon père que je fais ça
pas forcément le masque parce que c'est
pas facile mais au moins respecter les
distances d'un mètre de sécurité un
moyen malgré tout de relâcher un peu la
pression pour ces retrouvailles en
famille